Most, hogy egy éves lett a csatornám, és
körülbelül 30 epizódot leforgattam,
rájöttem, hogy igazából csak két dolog
az, ami működik a tanácsok közül, hogy
hogyan lesz eg csatorna
népszerű. Az első a bélyekkép. Tényleg
egy jó bélyegképet érdemes tervezni,
ugyanis az emberek nem kattintanak rá,
hogyha a bélyekkép nem érdekes. A
második pedig a tartalom. Hogyha a
tartalom nem izgalmas, és nem vagyok
eléggé felkészült, akkor nem fogják
megnézni az emberek. Az összes többi
technika, trükk nem működik, vagy
legalábbis alig működik. Javasolták azt,
hogy legyen a podcastem rendszeres,
jelenjen meg a hétnek ugyanazon a
napján, ugyanabban az órában. És még egy
nagy listányi dolgot javasoltak, de úgy
látom, hogy igazából a nagyon nagy
többségében csak ez a két dolog
működött. Tartalom és a békkép.
A